You know,
people say that's worth more than money
and that's worth more than money.
I know lots of people who have lots of
money and let me tell you,
money protects you,
your as well protected from the world by
money right now as you ever will be for
the rest of your life because there's
most of life's fundamental problems
can't be solved with money.
You know,
like rich people get divorced,
they have affairs,
their children get sick,
that they have all the problems you
have,
and that's partly because you're already
rich and so
you might think that if you had a bunch
of more money,
things would be better,
but it's just not true.
In fact,
in some ways that they might be worse
because money can open up,
can open up the possibility of all sorts
of temptations to you that you just
can't afford at the moment.
So well.
So like economic economics,
we've already solved that problem
fundamentally and we're rapidly solving
it everywhere in the world,
right?
I mean,
the world economy is growing so damn
fast that you can't even imagine how you
could possibly make it grow any faster.
It's crazy.
We've lifted hundreds of millions of
people out of poverty in the last 15
years.
You know,
the UN set a goal by 2015,
I think it was to cut poverty by half if
I remember correctly.
And they reached two years early.
You know,
it's like,
it's unbelievable.
So.
Well.
So then I started to try to understand
what it might be to,
to live and,
and really what I was looking forward to
was not so much to live a life that was
wise,
but at least to live a life that wasn't
pathologically unwise.
And I thought of the sorts of things
that people were doing to one another in
the Auschwitz camps and in the Gulag
archipelago and all of that horror that
was perpetrated on,
on people as definitely unwise.
Whatever else you might say about it was
unwise.
And so then I thought,
well maybe there's a way to figure out
how you could not do that.
And so that's.
And I think that that's my sense is that
when you come to university to learn how
to be a civilized person,
which is what supposed to happen at
university,
otherwise it's just a trade school and
you might as well go to trade school as
far as I'm concerned.
If you want to learn something that will
get you a job,
it's like it's a lot faster and it's
more certain and,
and it's useful.
If you're not being taught to be a
citizen at university,
then
why bother with it so?
Well.
So that's what we're trying to figure
out.
And,
and that's part of that cloud of
mythological fantasy that surrounds our
culture.
That's part of its deep history that
we're trying to,
you know,
if you grapple with the humanities and
with art and all of that,
that you're trying to,
you're trying to master and incorporate
and,
and pull into you so that you're
situated properly in history and,
and you're not just floating in the void
of,
you know,
this tiny individuality that's divorced
from everything else.
You're weak and that circumstance.
Right?
So
that's more of an explanation of why I'm
trying to puzzle through these things
and trying to puzzle through them with
you.
So anyways,
we talked about this,
this,
this song last week and you know,
I,
I made a hypothesis to you.
We'll,
we'll go through this quickly.
It's Doggerel.
It's not great poetry,
but it's irrelevant.
It was a very popular song.
It's quite beautiful in the movie.
It's actually sung by like a heavenly
choir.
That's what it sounds like.
So it's got this cathedral.
You could imagine people singing it in a
cathedral essentially.
And so that's not accidental.
It's purposeful,
you know,
it,
it partakes of that,
what would you call it?
It,
it partakes of that aesthetic,
that that's,
that's it.
So the,
the filmmakers are,
are implying that what is about to be
shown to you has this divine element
essentially,
and that that's signified by the choir
of voices that sings this song.
And the song says fundamentally
something like this is that if you lift
up your eyes above the temporal,
into the transcendent,
and so that's what exists in the
heavenly world in the stars.
If you pick a an ultimate goal,
if you pick the right ultimate goal,
then and you know anyone can do this.
That's the other thing.
It's democratic.
It's,
it's anyone can do this,
so that's,
that's the second proposition.
It doesn't matter who you are,
you can do this,
and so I think that's a reflection of
the idea of the divinity of the
individual.
It's like there's something about each
individual that's valuable regardless of
their idiosyncrasies and so they have
this potential that they can manifest.
And how do you manifest it?
Well,
you pick the right goal and what's the
right goal?
Well,
it's,
it's high,
it's elevated,
it's above the mundane.
Now what does that mean?
Well,
you don't really know.
You don't really know.
That's why it's signified by a star and
a star is something that glimmers in the
night,
right?
So it's a source of light in the
darkness.
And so there's a metaphor there.
Obviously there's a metaphor there and
the star is the star that the star of
Hollywood,
you know the person that you emulate.
That's part of it because it's an ideal
is it's going to be a human ideal,
some sort that you're aiming at and so
the ideal human being is,
is the star that you're aiming at?
Maybe it's something like that.
If that's what you're aiming at,
you might say,
well,
what should you aim at in life?
And wanting to answer as well,
why don't you aim at being whatever you
could be.
That would be the best.
No,
you don't know what that is exactly
because how do you,
you know,
but you could think,
well that would be really good if I
could have it.
And then you could say,
well,
can I think of anything better than
that?
And if the answer is no,
then well why not go for that?
You know?
And you might say,
well it's too ambitious.
It takes too much responsibility.
It's like,
yeah,
that,
those are definitely problems.
And one of the things that I've figured
out over the years is that if you
offered the person the opportunity,
you know,
because people say,
well,
life doesn't really have any ultimate
meaning.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
fine.
So far,
let's say it has an ultimate meaning,
but that in order to experience that
ultimate meaning,
you have to take on ultimate
responsibility for what you do.
Well,
that's a heavy price to pay,
to have a meaningful life,
you know,
and you might say,
well,
there's no damn way I'm going to do
that.
I'll just go for the,
you know,
pointless.
Ah,
I'll go for that.
The trivial pointless perspective,
which you know,
was kind of hard on me existentially,
but it frees me up.
I can do whatever the hell I want moment
to moment.
I don't have any ultimate
responsibility.
And so then you think,
well that's kind of a good deal.
And then then.
But that raises this weird specter of
doubt,
which is why when you hear people talk
about the ultimate futility of life,
is it because life is ultimately futile?
Or is it because they've decided that
they would just assume not adopt the
responsibility and they use that real
decision,
which is to not adopt the
responsibility.
They rationalize that by proposing that
life is ultimately meaningful,
meaningless and like,
you know,
I kind of by that I really do think
that's what's going on so,
but maybe not,
but it could be that if you want to have
an ultimately meaningful life that you
have to adopt ultimate responsibility.
Makes Sense.
What might that mean?
Well,
one thing it might mean is that,
and I do think it means this is it.
I think it was Alexander Pope,
but I might be wrong about that.
Who said nothing human is foreign to me
and that's a hell of a statement,
right?
Because if you think about all the
things that human beings are capable of,
they're capable of some,
like if you really want to know what
people are capable of,
you should read about read about unit
seven slash 31,
but I would not recommend it because if
you read it,
you will never forget it and you will be
sorry that you read it,
but you'll know anyways to say that
nothing human is foreign to you.
That's a hell of a thing to say because
that means that what other people have
done you could do,
and that also means you need to take
responsibility for that.
That's no joke.
You know,
it's a big deal to do that and even
trivial manner anyway,
so the idea is that you can elevate.
If you elevate your viewpoint to some
transcendent ethic,
you want what's ultimately good.
You really want that.
Whatever that is you don't know,
but that's what you're even out says
that,
well then it says this strange thing
well,
what you want,
we'll all of a sudden come to you.
Well,
that's a proposition and it's the
proposition that's basically played out
in the movie.
It's a hypothesis.
The hypothesis is the best way to Orient
yourself in life is to orient yourself
towards the highest good that you're
capable of imagining and then aim at
that and then things will work out the
best way they can for you.
And I think,
I believe that's correct.
My,
my observation of life has led me to see
that that seems to be correct.
So for example,
you don't get something you don't aim at
that just doesn't work out and so lots
of people are not thinking that's what
they get.
So if you aim at something,
you have a reasonable crack at getting
it,
you know,
you tend to change what you're aiming at
a bed along the way because like what
are,
you know,
game there,
you're wrong,
but you get a little closer and then the
aim there and you're still wrong,
you get a little closer and the aim
there and you know,
as you move towards what you're aiming
at,
your,
your characterization of what to aim at
becomes more and more sophisticated.
And so it doesn't really matter if
you're wrong to begin with,
as long as you're smart enough to learn
on the way and as long as you specify a
goal.
So I specify a vague what I want things
to be the best they could be and I'm
willing to learn what best means as I go
along.
Okay?
So fine.
And then you get what you truly need
will say,
well,
maybe not.